that's where we get into your territory
but where you can be pissed off about it
or see it as overreach you break into
the US capital there is absolutely no
proof that it was an orchestrated event
by confidential informants uh this
happened do I think it was an
Insurrection no okay by definition it
was not an Insurrection and it was not
an act of Terror but it was a really
ugly reflection of where we are and I
can get that people are going to be
prosecuted for it uh should the degree
of that prosecution and the punishment
you can argue that part but your main
point Christopher Ray yeah is a lifelong
Republican as is Bob Mueller when Trump
put Ray in he loved his ass the idea
that he then all a sudden transformed
into this Manchurian Candidate who is
there to undercut the right is nonsense
now does he give double speak and deal
with things that he should answer
straight and doesn't and does that fuel
your misgivings yes yes and yes so I'm
with you I'm with you um do I believe
January 6 was a setup no I don't
believe it was a setup I also don't
believe it was an Insurrection I believe
it was ex exaggerated in terms of why it
happened and what actually happened
because people were scared and they
could play to Advantage the same way
happened with the BLM riots right I'm
one of the tools of this Chris Cuomo
said where in the constitution does it
say that protests are supposed to be
peaceful uh right in the first line of
the First Amendment obviously I know
that what was I saying is that when
people were saying who are all these
black people and their allies shouting
at the cops go home I was making the
point hey look this is protest protest
isn't going to be nice people are going
to be saying things that are angry and
hostile they're outraged we need this in
a democracy It's upsetting but we need
it I wasn't saying that you're not
allowed to peacefully assemble maybe I'm
a shitty lawyer but I know what the
First Amendment says but why would
people twist my point that's the game
why would people twist what Ray says or
doesn't say that's the game and I just
don't know where it gets us and I I
don't want to I don't want to sit on it
just really fast with January 6 I don't
want to beat the dead horse but H how
then what do you say Chris when the
ex-chief of police Steven son said by
the way this guy is's the most trusted
guy you can't just all of a sudden
Pelosi on them try to make him look like
he was full of that guy has top
secret clar take at his work he's a G
right Chris he said they had warnings
that people were going to be violent
there was threats to life so to not give
him the resources that he wanted to hold
on a mistake why though I want to go
deeper to go why why would you turn down
his call for the National Guard so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right
here